tomorrow's inauguration Trump's gonna be
our new president you have claimed that
you were an influence on trouble well
you know what it is the guy like stole
my whole act on TV don't I'm gonna teach
doing me and he's wearing the red tie
with the white shirt like he's Rodney
Dangerfield yeah you're not waiting for
the guy to come out and go okay man
everything's all right just taking all
my bits and I'm saying if I taught it at
first tomorrow would be my day to be
like invigorated inaugurated we'll get
to that no cuz I know you had all those
arguments with Hillary 490 man yeah you
know and I'm thinking the guy could get
his point across in 30 seconds yeah yeah
come out and tell the American public
what you can really get done
you